hi hi
um theater certainly
um what did you make of it
I thought that in the arraignment
proceedings he looked subdued and
genuinely worried about what was
happening
um and he's never actually had to face
this before and I thought it was uh it
was a side of Donald Trump yourself and
see you looked a bit vulnerable then a
thought in front of his audience of
supporters Mar-A-Lago you saw classic
Trump he feeds off the energy of his
supporters and he was out there at his
bombastic best or worst depending on
your viewpoint
some of his comments
um
well quite obviously um
uh not true shall we say the best
um do you think he knows that when he
says what he says I honestly think that
he has in his head a sort of alternative
version of reality
do you think he thinks that the truth is
a single point of light in a dark sky I
think he thinks there's a range of
options for the truth in any case and he
will always choose the one that's
favorable to him so I don't think he
ever believes that he is he is
deliberately um deliberately uh lying to
people I think he just thinks that it's
uh you know it's a it's a reality that
uh that stands up in his own mind and
should stand up with the minds of others
was there anything that particularly
stood out from the speech for you not
really um I mean I thought he had a
slightly different line
from saying his usual stuff about a
Witch Hunt to saying this was
interference in the election process so
he's you know he wanted something new to
say to his supporters last night and
that was slightly new but it's the same
line essentially that he is being
victimized it's like his lawyers took
outside the courtroom yesterday which is
that if we're not for it being Donald J
Trump
um you know on the stand these these
this this Arrangement this case would
never have been brought
politics enable we'll drizzle down a
little bit further he was talking about
what was happening with China with the
Iran uh with Russia
um and it also talked about Ukraine
saying that wouldn't have happened if
he'd been president
yeah I mean the Ukraine Point that's
stretching it frankly what we remember
about Donald Trump as president was him
always talking about what a great
relationship he had with Vladimir Putin
um about which up to a point is true up
to a point you never really knew what
Putin thought about Trump
um and remember he sided with Putin on
there having been no evidence of of
Russian interference in the elections
against his own security authorities who
said they had so it was a very strange
relationship with Putin
and he didn't want to see the Ukrainian
president unless the ukrainians would
try and dig up some dirt on Hunter Biden
so I think his record on Ukraine is
pretty mixed remember the day of the
invasion
um February last year his first reaction
was that it was something like it was a
genius move by Vladimir Putin he
corrected himself a bit later but that
was his first reaction that's always
quite telling the idea that Donald Trump
can come in and resolve Ukraine in 24
hours I think is pretty far-fetched how
much of a tightrope is he walking by
criticizing openly the judge and the
district attorney given what was said in
the courtroom yesterday
I thought he might at least back off on
that and he didn't in his speech or
maybe the occasion you know he just
couldn't help himself but I think that's
quite dangerous I saw an American lawyer
talking about the senior American lawyer
um and he said it might not affect how
the trial goes but when it comes to if
he is found guilty the judge has a range
of options from A Fine up to a prison
sentence and the insults that have been
put his way by Donald Trump may affect
how he how he sees things so I think
he's walking a tightrope on this and if
I were him I'd be advising if his
lawyers I'd be advising him to back down
on this stuff but I'm not sure I mean
there's not another court case now until
December which is a very long way away
then if there is a trial it'll be at the
very earliest January we're into the
run-up to the elections after that if
he's going to run you know he'll be
it'll be in court and also running to be
president at the same time it's a good
question first of all his lawyers will
use the next few months to basically try
and get the case dismissed and there are
independent lawyers not Trump supporters
independent lawyers in the American
system who have written that they think
this case is
really quite questionable and there is
some quite novel legal theory behind
what the prosecuting attorney is trying
to do and it may just not stick who
knows
um and then if they can't actually get
it dismissed then they will try every
delaying tactic they can to get the
hearing to get the hearing now scheduled
for December put back and put back and
put back
um and you know let's see what happens
uh will be their view on that so I
wouldn't guarantee it'll happen in if
he's president can you appear in court
um I think that if he actually becomes
president a second time
and you haven't had the hearing and you
haven't had the um you know a verdict I
suspect it falls away but I'm not a I'm
not a lawyer you need to or we need to
check got plenty of those on later on
um was there anything that surprised you
when the documents were unsealed
um uh we've heard that there might be as
many as 30 different charges in it in
fact there were 34
um uh this case or this angle of this
doorman who was paid off was news at
least to me now this was as just so if
our viewers don't know this was a
doorman who apparently was given more
than a significant imagine thousands of
dollars because he allegedly knew about
a love child
um yeah yeah and then there was a second
um hosh money case involving another
another lady
um which uh hadn't come out beforehand
but all of the charges were basically
along the same lines just lots of
different cases of falsification records
so there was nothing new there in terms
of you know a big new charge that was
going to break the whole thing open and
the overarching case is that
misappropriation of monies that could
have influenced the 20 16 elections yeah
um I mean what they are saying is that
the records were falsified and the
information was concealed in order to
affect the outcome of the 2016 election
that's how you get from a misdemeanor
which there's no prison sentence to a
felony okay uh what about his what about
ism
um in what sense while he was talking
about uh he was throwing mud everywhere
Biden particularly oh yeah but that's
just classic Trump and he always does
that
um like there is some parallels and
depending what's happening to him and
you know this all this stuff about
Hunter Biden's laptop and whatever and
basically there isn't
um
taken there was um preferential
treatment for the president there was
there was but I mean if you look at why
you would need a mug shot I mean this is
the most recognizable individual or
Planet arguably so I'm not sure they
really needed it I think King Charles
might have something to say about I
think he was fingerprinted he was yeah
he was fingerprinted but um I don't
think it's unreasonable for them to make
a few a few concessions because it's an
ex-president there I mean this is still
I promise you Trump will heat every
second of this because although he talks
all the time about fake news he cares
profoundly and perhaps more about this
than about anything else about how he is
seen in the rest of the world in the
media and uh all of this publicity This
Global publicity he absolutely hate it
so it's bad enough for him without him
being photographed but it looks as
though Republican voters are laughing
out but he's doing stormingly well and
raising millions of pounds for his
campaign what I noticed Kay when I was
when I was in Washington and it's the
same here his opinion polls go up and
down and you know the effect of an event
on opinion polls lasts about two or
three weeks and then things start to
settle down again so you're right um he
has gone in a week and a half from eight
points ahead of Ron DeSantis who hasn't
even yet declared yet to 26 points ahead
and he seems to raise about 10 million
dollars in money and that all makes it
look as if it's playing for him but this
is a very long game we are nine months
off the first primary and uh you know a
year and a half more than a year and a
half off the election so let's see how
this plays out and let's see whether
those opinion polls stay as well and
remember this case the Stormy Daniels
case is the first cab off the rank but
there are three more potential cases
against him all of which if they if they
come to indictments are much much more
serious yeah I wonder why they went with
this one
um it's just that that this was the
first I mean this Manhattan district
attorney
um prepared his case he's been he's been
researching it for a long time and
that's the way it works just happened to
be the first one to come off
documents in documents of Mar-A-Lago the
the Georgia interference the Georgia
election where remember Trump is
recorded as having rung up the head of
the election process 11
000 votes and then a potential federal
case about Trump's involvement potential
incitement of the invasion of the
capital in sixth January indeed Just
Before I Let You Go I mean there's no
love loss between the two of you as we
know when you think about Donald Trump
um you're back here in the UK and you
think about him what memory comes into
your mind
inevitably inevitably his reaction when
um my uh my letter reporting my
classified letter reporting
um how he was doing came out which was I
remember I was waiting for about 24
hours until
um until he was up playing golf in his
course in in New York and I knew he
would react and there was there was a
fairly not a long wait until he actually
landed on the White House lawn and um
then the journalists cussed around him
and then he said his remarks about um uh
how lowly he rated me
um and of course you know I knew from
that moment on that basically I was
going to have to resign I was suspected
I would because difficulty the job after
you written about the president in that
way there were earlier moments like when
I took Theresa May in to see him as the
first foreign visitor just a couple of
days after his inauguration in which I
saw a different side of domino Trump but
it all ended like it ended
fascinating stuff my Lord thank you for
taking the time to join us